my name is Caitlin Cassidy and my super
year out project is about helping
teachers give better feedback on
students code so let's take like a class
at MIT that's teaching students how to
program in Java teachers already do a
great job of giving students feedback so
they look at every student's code and
give them personalized feedback and they
also give students feedback immediately
so that day or the day after
so my project is about helping teachers
give better feedback by changing what
they look at typically once teachers
grade code they only look at a student's
final code and we're investigating
whether if teachers can see in addition
to final code all the steps that
students took along the way whether
teachers can give students better
feedback
so our final interface is this one in
the middle so on this left side we can
see all the students final code so it's
as if they press submit at the end the
code on the left is their final code but
in addition we have this code on the
right side over here that you can see in
red and that's code that the students
typed and then deleted at some point in
the middle so it kind of highlights all
the steps that students took along the
way to get to the final product to test
whether this actually improves feedback
we ran an experiment in in an MIT
classroom and we found two metrics that
say that teachers give longer feedback
so on average if they were looking at an
old interface that just showed final
code teachers use about forty-three
characters on average to give feedback
and now with our interface they give
forty nine and a half characters in
addition before about 80 percent of
comments were above ten characters which
is already great right so less than ten
is maybe if they said good or great job
as a comment only so eighty percent
above that is awesome but we increase
that to 90 percent so we're seeing much
longer feedback given by TAS or teachers
who can see a student's code history as
well as their final code we also did a
qualitative assessment about teachers
comments so some students were graded
once without the extra code and so so
30% of students were graded once without
the extra visualization and once with
and qualitatively looking at all those
feedback we saw that teachers did give
better comments so as one example over
here
if the teachers only looked at final
code they just thought that the students
didn't do anything but when we can see
that the student actually did something
shown in red on the right the teacher
said good start you're on the right
track which is much better feedback for
the student and is going to improve
their learning